what is going on there reject nation greg here
today i'm about to check out the movie prey a film
i'm very much excited for i'm a big fan of the
predator franchise i like the movie 10 cloverfield
lane which is the same director couple of things
i got to acknowledge yeah i am shooting this a
little bit early because i have an interview
to do with the director and a couple members
of the cast for this film so that interview
should already be up on the channel before
this one is another quick disclaimer i've seen
those comments come in people assuming there's
this automatic bias of recommendation just because
we've talked to some of the filmmakers or talent
involved with the movie let me refer you to our
eternal's reaction our mortal kombat reaction
our hawkeye reaction you'll see we were very
very much not shy to be harsh on our criticism
for those properties while we still interview
the talent so if i end up not liking this i'll
be honest with you guys i just won't tell them
that i'll just focus on what i liked about it
when talking with them and yes i am shooting
this by myself right now because john a few
days ago he tested positive for the diesel as i
called it i myself tested positive for it i still
have it right now but i i just talked to john
i'm definitely feeling much better than him i'm
healing i'm a superhuman like i said i'm a massive
fan of the predator franchise really looking
forward to this if you guys can leave a like be
very much appreciated also subscribe click that
notification bell get notified when we got another
movie reaction up here on the channel full length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up with
the time code are available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page become a sexy
reject today by checking out all we got to offer
over there lastly the team at prepper thank you
guys for helping us out and down these highlights
would not be in the position we are today if it
wasn't for all you let's get into action people
a long time ago it is said a monster came here
beautiful opening shot
beautiful music so far
that dog better not die
badass i hope you guys watch this movie with
headphones because there's some
incredible sound design already
oh
yeah who is this chick she is
badass no oh what a bunch of [__]
i swear the dog better not die
gonna has to use that that trap on the predator
this morning in the sky i saw a sign the
thunderbird it's time i'm ready for my katamiya
you really think you're ready you want
to hunt something that's hunting you
you're gonna get exactly what you want
this is such a great shot is that for warchief's
bad knee hmm he's getting worse you didn't put on
who taught you about orange tortilla
you you'll have to use orange tootsia
when you're fighting against the
predator go get us some orange tutsia
such a good buildup oh
i'm really enjoying this movie's
grip on the atmosphere so much
don't worry you're gonna get to
prove yourself with the ultimate prey
hina a lion he took buoy you gotta find him
this movie's already way better
than that shane black one
what the [__]
who invited you she tracks well
and if we find fuji alive she knows
medicine that dude's got a cool voice
i hate snakes that's a great shot though
kill that snake
what a cool perspective shot i don't like animal
deaths but some reason snakes so the one the main
thing that i can handle you see that crushed bone
that's lying scared the cat that made it was big
if it bleeds we can kill it
god i love how like immediate and
pulsating this is he's breathing that's her
so much could kill him it won't
kill him just cool his blood
cool his blood that will come in handy why is puji
alive there's something that scared the cat away
from its den i've got this we don't have time to
waste talking we need to get him home my number
she's the only one being smart or
at least asking the smart questions
she's great there's a lot of life behind her eyes
look it could be bear tracks but that's a big bear
and why was it on its hind legs and what skin
to snake like that we need to keep moving
no i have to warn my brother aren't
you guys the slightest bit curious
i love the use of the tribal drums like captures
that like a heartbeat in a way i found tracks
and they were huge i'm not frightened by a bear
i don't know what it was i've never seen anything
like it or whatever it was we're in the cat's
den now we have to deal with the first you guys
are too cool when the lion comes you tell that
thing this is as far as you go no more this is it
i'm really loving the main
girl's performance a lot
it's there's so much nuance
happening with her expressions
this interest curiosity fear courage is all
like layered into one sense of body language
when your brother comes back he and i
will find the lion and kill him oh my god
your brother carried you home what about the lion
oh they went after it sorry i have to find him
no you need to rest oh man they're
all gonna be dead by the morning
this is cool how it's capturing the
like the primal themes of predator
there's a lot of dead animals
so he returned her then went back out there
killed the lion and came back with a lion
this guy is just as cool as me we didn't do it
you're right we didn't do it i did you
tried it you couldn't bring it home
don't you worry you're gonna have the
greatest opportunity to prove yourself
i don't know why i get almost like
a sort of like survival video game
vibe it's not exactly that but you
kind of get the impression of it
guys i'm telling you i found green blood
it doesn't mean anything shut up woman
don't mess around with these animals
oh come on man i'm hating this predator
because of all the animal kills
oh don't do a wolfie
oh man
oh
there are so many animal deaths
to think i almost had my friend
andrew gordon watch this movie with me he
can't he really can't add all animal baths
nice yo-yo axe i wonder if
she was really doing that
please don't kill the dog
holy balls
oh man you better [__] this
predator up i swear to god
yikes
there's something incredible
sound design in this film
wow what a hell of a shot
come on oh good thing you're covered
in all that mud i feel like they're
just planting so many seeds for the final battle
that bear's dead
great
goddammit
no puppy
i'm hoping the predator gets to
it before the gets to the dog
nice
holy [__] mom you're not
gonna believe what i just saw
[__] terrifying damn
oh it's got him it's got the bear
there's some blood in its mouth
bears lee's putting up a fight
see how pissed of the
oh my god it's like drenched in blood yikes
it's like the invisible man on steroids
holy crap
there's such great use of setting
in this film like with the
all the man versus nature qualities to it and
things you can get trapped in and just your
environments it's so well utilized i'm really
digging this movie a lot this is really good
it's a really good [__] what are you doing
here looking for you your brother sent us to
bring you home i'm ready for them to not believe a
single thing she says i saw what left those tracks
it fought and killed a bear with its
hands easily how come it didn't kill you
nice good for you good for you
damn this guy can't get one hit
you want to leave
oh my god
oh [__]
just sick
just don't put a weapon in her hands
yet you need a leash for your weapon
don't talk all she's [__] tough
man he's got your ass kicked
he did it guys what do you
think drove the possums our way
here you're about to about to suck some dick man
whoa that's different
that would be a good time
gnarly
i'd just be shouting i told you so
oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh god here it is
i don't believe you
again this [__] music man
the trailer moment let's get some
serious nipple chills right now
we have him
no he has us
that was a terrifying shot
oh my god
oh great
oh here we go
if the predator hasn't used a gun yet
will they get a gun from these guys
oh good there's a whole whole settlement
here to slaughter for the predator
you killed the buffalo ah what
did you see you are come on cheers
they're kind of hunt for red
october ringing it right yeah okay
if you were smart you'd help us tell
us something like the last sacred point
oh no
are you hurt
oh they tried he's got a billy's car
although i did that all stealthily it's coming
wow
something almost demonic about it you
want to know how i killed that lion
your plan you had it naru
you can see what i missed
i don't know that this thing can be killed
if it bleeds we can kill it we can kill it
wow
yep
trap on his guy said that was cool
i don't know how you're
gonna defeat this thing man
it's like wonder woman on no man's land losing his
leg to be free wait not what are you doing nader
nada stop i'm smarter than a beaver you
really set it up like you're gonna cut a
limb off all right just go back to your
tribe and throw away all your weapons
let's put your face right up and
then spit your face right up in it
wow he didn't even want to
waste his time with them
nice work
damn
oh damn
queen that's a gritty ass one take shot man
sure there was like one hidden cut in there
i think there's like just enough of like early
stage predator you know what i mean the the
technology stuff but he also seems to have like
kind of a larger quantity of weapons too much
you put in the gunner three four times it's okay
he just shoots her and the movie
what easy
hahaha
his blood is cold
you really get that feel of like this
ferocious man slash beast in that predator suit
you done [__] up man i can't see it cold blood
i thought he was gonna step
like on his heart or something
no that hell no
oh my god thank god
wow gross
sometimes it feels like video game levels i
love it there you go hey oh pooh good shot
not too much not too little
nice man
oh cowardly predator this is as far as i go
oh i really like that guy it bumps me up
i think the way they've they've captured
the predator here feels like uh some type
of ferocious hybrid of man and beast that
arose from nature as opposed to like
an alien from an alien from space
what's she gonna do with him
oh my goodness
you bled my brother so now you bleed
you can't see but i'm killing you
and it won't either
man you become a cold-hearted badass
that's what happens when your brother dies
the predator is legit scary in this
nice work
nice oh we hit a predator finale
oh [__] is this like snowing
or is it just flowers falling
cool i love it i love the look of it
yes and the cold breath ah i love it
nice nice
damn this player just got some parkour skills man
oh my god oh my god
harley
i love the aesthetics here
he's got the axe in this
oh [__] it came back yes
that's [__] terrifying it's like a
goddamn lord of the rings orc in this movie
come on come on come on come on do it
dude now this is as far as you go no more
this is such a cool movie
oh you feel like a cathartic release right there
i don't think i've ever rooted for a character
this much in a predator franchise like not not
one character i've ever like come on do i kill
i'm a hunter
we need to move to easier protected
ground is that the predator 2 gun
i thought that was a different gun over
my right half is it the predator too good
my god historical fiction at its finest
i'm alive
[__] yeah we got a great ass predator
movie not since the first one we finally
got a great predator movie holy crap that was
great that was really great holy god i just
this franchise been so up and down and we finally
got a great ass predator film i was so happy with
that man that was amazing like how they're
doing the end credits designs a lot making
its way in history this is how the story will be
told the cast was so good too oh god i can't wait
to talk about this like with others and stuff i
can't wait to share the enthusiasm for this film
is that a setup for live more coming the
comanche nation booyah such great music too ah
ah it's pumped it feels so good to
truly have a great predator film again
and so like obviously it pays pays like clear
tribute to things in the first movie but i love
how it feels like so different in many many many
ways other than the predictable like oh we're
gonna go to the finale arc uh showdown which is
one-on-one setting up the trappings i really love
the immediacy of it that was uh that was great it
was great great art direction too all right let's
talk about it people all right as much as i said
that thing at the beginning about like you know
hey just because i'm going to interview talent
involved with the film doesn't mean i'm gonna
you know be shy of criticizing
a movie if i don't like it
give examples at the beginning of this video
to show like i'm willing to do it but now i'm
gotta be honest with you guys i i'm i'm just
excited to do the interviews now because
that was amazing who am i oh [__]
i'm interviewing the main people that
made them two main characters i didn't
realize that they never give us the leads
hell yeah oh sweet okay um wow where to begin that
was just like solid it was solid it's like crisp
it's tight it's tense it's exciting it's
atmospheric it's dreadful but it's got this great
rhythm to it throughout it's like pulsating you
know like the the use of the drums uh throughout
with the with like the kind of like tribal
music i thought just really played on the
heart so well and added to the intensity
of the film throughout and this character
am i trying too hard am i trying too hard
the actress's name amber mid thunder wow
what a cool name holy christ um damn amber
mid thunder what a name like that wow anywho
just redefining what the name amber means but um
yeah the uh her character i was so invested in
from the very beginning of this story because it's
it's so multi-layered with her performance of how
she's someone who obviously has like a lot of
fear there's already a lot of compounding weight
placed against her from just the
conditions of what she's grown up with
of the the with a societal point of view within
her her tribe her family of telling her who she
really can be and what she's trying to be she just
plain and simple shouldn't so you do have that
investment in her of you want to watch her rise
and become the ultimate hunter warrior and that
was kind of the the whole mood and vibe of this
entire film was like that primal feeling of
hunter warrior it made it feel more visceral
because this this film is so immediate and
and while being so tense and taught it it was
one of those like character driven performances
not through like getting a bunch of exposition or
monologuing or something like that or just having
like a butt like it was just enough scenes to
establish it but really you're watching the growth
of this person arc into you know utilizing their
strengths by to the end of the film and i like
how like the the death of her brother is the
catapult into her getting to the like i don't
give a [__] point and like it creates kind of
this this hardness within her and that's like
the final step in her growth to be able to take
on the ultimate enemy which is his predator and
i thought the way the predator was used felt
so cool you know like the predator at times
you know like don't get me wrong like i i actually
have a soft spot for uh most of the predator films
uh even like the first alien versus predator
film i have a soft spot for i like predator
too i i really grew up watching both predator 1
and predator 2 constantly it was just a constant
in my household a film that maybe a little kid
shouldn't be watching but i was obsessed with them
i really loved them and i even liked the robert
rodriguez film predators but this easily easily
like i don't i wouldn't want to declare it
as the best predator film out of the whole
franchise there are things about it right away
mood wise that just draw to my sensibilities and
my my personal tastes so much stronger than even
the first original john mctiernan predator film
but i can't like confidently sit here and
as easily establish like this is the best
predator movie but i can definitely
say this is the best predator movie
since the original and you know it's kind of
this conflicting feeling because because of
the fact that it's going to hulu i gotta
watch a screener and you know i get a
chance to share my reaction with you guys so yeah
there's that benefit but this is like how many how
many films that have disappointed fans uh in the
predator move franchise have gone to the theaters
and and this one is not getting that which which
is such a bummer because there's so many great
things from just a filmmaking technical standpoint
like the cinematography doesn't feel quite
necessarily to the same like the level of the
revenant which was all like natural lighting
we just use natural lighting but it really
does capture the reflective lighting of the
environment really using the surfaces it has
really using the weather using those conditions
and the cinematography which was excellent like
the color palette was great it was really visually
striking throughout and this the set designs and
the costumes like the overall art production was
was amazing uh really brought it to life and like
i'm i'm i'm a dummy who doesn't know enough about
like comanche history i don't know anything
about it all right i don't know jack about it
and and so and like my american history is already
like a little bit muddied uh enough as it is so
i i don't really i'm not a historian in here to
to talk with you guys however i do get the sense
that they at least like uh aiming to honor you
know uh the native american tribe that i i get
that sense to say the least and because you get
the you really get the vibe in the culture sense
bottom line is like there was a cultural sense
throughout this whole film that was constantly
permeating uh for beginning to end with each one
of these characters that felt very lived in in
that regard and that's a big part of why i thought
it was so effective and emotionally effective
because while it's like the only characters i
really care about are the two main characters
the brother and the sister um that was just
enough for a film that is as as tight as this
where it's like it's it's weird because you're
like you have the you have the the forest you
have the wilderness you have the nature you got
the waterfalls you got everything at the river
yet it still felt very contained i love the
immediacy and the buildup of it throughout and
regarding the predator the predator i know some
of this i said like during my reaction so excuse
me if i repeat myself from time to time there
were parts of this predator that i did find more
ferocious uh it it kind of had the sense of like a
hard r rated version of whatever that main orc was
in the fellowship of the ring but this this you
know creature definitely a lot smarter more more
clever more coy and more tactile obviously not
just some rampaging beasts but you kind of get
the qualities of both you get the qualities of the
skillful hunter but something that does feel more
beast-like and more ruthless uh throughout and
i like i like the performance of whoever played
the predator because you do feel like part that's
part of what makes the predator even more eerie
is despite how foreign it is and you know like
it's such a creature such a sci-fi creature yet
because of its humanoid qualities that's a big
part of what makes the creature so unsettling
and i thought that was really brought back
here and that's something that's kind of been
missing you know like i think a lot of the time
with these predator films they try like while
you have your your little line homages and and
some structural things and and certain moments
that are clearly harkening back to the original
predator film it it was really doing its own thing
and embodying the time period and the environment
that this this encapsulated because this also did
have that backdrop and mood of films kind of like
the edge and revenant which uh have that you know
man versus nature quality and i like that that
was very much utilized throughout this film as
well because because the the the feel of the
game of the hunt you know and and establishing
the groundwork like when she gets trapped in the
is that quicksand whatever that mud is that she's
slowly slowly fall into and you know some things
become a little bit predictable like when they say
the blood is gonna make you make your blood cold
like okay she's gonna be able to use that um you
know and certain certain things that they would
clearly let's focus on this because we're gonna
definitely be using this later on in the movie pay
close attention to that uh i thought was cool and
i like it's like video game qualities at times it
does feel like a level at times with the the pov
of fighting in the wilderness uh it does feel like
a survival horror game and that's another theme
that it really captures strongly of that or or
the the mood the the feel such a survival horror
movie as well and uh and even like the girl the
nauru's character this dog whatever the dog's name
is it did kind of feel like that dog helper friend
in a video game and it always made me afraid that
they were gonna kill that dog uh man i gotta warn
some people because i know a lot of people who
can't watch movies if there's if there's like a
really if there's like one harsh animal death but
there's like this many like there's no way they
can handle this and uh yeah because like i was
andrew gordon watch this with me and uh he's he's
like this out of all my friends he's usually the
biggest predator fan but because of the fact
that i got the vid right now i was like you
you shouldn't be next to me and uh i'm glad he
wasn't here because this was this is brutal in
that and i liked seeing those early stages of
the predator like coming to earth and being
like what's the ultimate warrior here and you know
you have back then the humans as hunters uh they
this was their prey this is who they this is
what they hunted these these types of animals
these threats and so when you have the predator
plop down here and the predator is now hunting
what the humans hunt and it's just a walk in the
park for the predator it's like nothing so easy um
except for the bear i like that and i like the
perspective captures that uh dan trachtenberg
was able to to do with certain moments of
like you you could just get that kind of
exciteful filmmaker sense of of like man if i
did a predator movie this is kind of the cool
things i'd want to do like with the bleeding
bear encompassing the camouflage stealth mode
version of the predator and that's the thing
that starts to illuminate you know outline
what the predator is but it's all like scuzzy
and messed up and i loved it i loved it i love
uh that this was like a hard r that it took
itself very serious uh the brother too uh dakota
beavers top tabby tabby you know you watch a whole
movie you still can't remember a character's name
i i liked uh how authentic and sincere and uh
sympathetic the the portrayal of the ultimate
warrior in the tribe uh was you know and as being
this force that helps motivate two you know and
he also was multi-layered because obviously he
loves his sister and he wants to protect her
and he wants to be there for her and support her
and show this you know show love you know be the
ultimate brother but clearly he he has his doubts
as well and he he fights against it and i like
that you got the sense of again three-dimensional
characters and and even giving some path it's not
something that pathos but yeah some some weight to
to the mom uh as well you know like while she can
be you know selling a little bit harsh at times
too that's our main lead uh you know there there's
there's such emotion behind her portrayal
as well like i thought the cast was great
the the violence and the action was really
well choreographed and really cool i loved
a lot of the tracking shots i liked that you could
see what the hell was going on even at times when
i was like okay we're going into dark environment
territory is this where we try to mask some [__]
that they couldn't quite do but no it it would
always provide a better like a more definitive
mood depending on whatever the sequence was and i
and i thought the action was like packed a punch
it was gory it was cool to look at there was
some awesome stylish choreography throughout
some worthwhile kills um yeah this was the [__]
i thought this film was awesome then the original
score was great i i did i don't really i guess
if i had like one quan but but it really subsided
uh pretty early on for me like other than the fact
that like some things are a little bit predictable
but as a fan of the predator franchise those are
just kind of tropes and motifs that i'd expect
when you got a story like this you know i'm not
expecting it to completely redefine cinema here
i'm not expecting it to like do some type of
like elevated meditative like thought process
of a film but it does kind of you know capture
a little bit more of that stimuli more than
most of these predator films man and uh uh i
totally lost my train of thought here oh yes the
the were they were they french they seem like
french clonius or settlers right they they they
see they seem french um i don't know about the
history i don't i don't i was like spanish or
french i don't speak either language seem french
um regardless with those characters who showed up
i i i guess i i would have liked a little
bit if there was anything more to like add
a you know a little bit more run time to the movie
for it would have been to kind of settle in with
them and not not that i was like i want to get to
know them and really care about them that wasn't
the case you know in some ways it did feel like
they were set up here so that way they could be
uh you know extra body counts but it and the
reason i'm saying that is because you know by
the time you meet them you barely spend any time
and then the next you know a lot of them are
getting you know you know uh getting killed off
uh and and to me i was like ah maybe there should
have been something that kind of and maybe there
was a line of dialogue that i that i missed i'm
gonna give the movie the benefit the downer you
guys clarify for me if there was something there
that i missed that established that you know other
than the first shadowing of the buffalo bean skin
where we thought it was the predator that was
doing it um other than that it i thought there
that could might have been used a little bit
of like foreshadowing that she would encounter
uh these people if they were aware of these people
who were out there um some little extra focus on
that because it did kind of come in so late and
the next thing you know a lot of them are getting
killed off however this film is captured so
much solely from the perspective of nauru i
think that's always her name whatever i'm going
with that of nauru that well yeah in this person's
perspective in this situation it's not like
they're getting foreshadowing in their life
they would just kind of stumble into the
situation i'm like okay so there's actually
a realistic touch to that that
i then began to appreciate
and you know the the fun fanboy in me just goes
well [__] you know like i thought they at least
packed a presence in the sense of like ruthless
[__] who shouldn't be here and are here doing
harmful [__] uh i i thought they packed that
presence and it just was rewarding to watch them
get killed off and yeah it leads to her getting
the gun and whatever i thought it was still very
rewarding and would i have liked there's a
little bit more screen time with them maybe
but as it stands i still thought it
was effective when they were there
i i really i really enjoyed that prize so yeah
like to me i think that's about the only thing
i might have a qualm with i don't personally
don't like that much animal death in some of that
so cruel but if it works it really sets you up for
like oh my god this predator i want to see this
predator die and that's another thing you know
like a lot of times with these predator movies
it's been a long time since i was like i want to
see this predator die and i really felt that like
i was so rooting for the main character that i'm
like yes kill the [__] predator and i'm just
glad that this to finally in this franchise
again get back to feeling that way because
that's what you want man the predator is
the bad guy like you gotta feel that way
and it's been a long time since i felt that
way and i i thought they brought back to a
real menacing scary imposing point again uh yeah
i i thought this was an excellent film um like
i would give it like a solid a at least and i
don't do great but here i am give it like a solid
a to say the least um as a fanboy the predator
franchise like it's an a plus for sure this was
excellent excellent stuff and yeah i'm actually
kind of like nervous to i gotta think of some
good questions because this was this was awesome
this was really really awesome i i really loved it
yeah i love this one i'm i'm excited to talk
with people about it because this was really
cool and i hope you guys enjoyed it too uh but
guys leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell leave a like subscribe to
get accepted no no no i say now subscribe
to become a citizen of the reject nation
much love people thank you for being here